[Music]
this morning on the dish the man who
might be the most famous chef
alive jacques papan has been cooking for
more than 70 years he was the personal
chef to three
french prime ministers before he turned
down president kennedy to work at howard
johnson's
he's been elevating the way americans
have been cooking and eating ever since
including over the last year as his
short online videos made during the
pandemic became a sensation
we met jacques pepin recently at his
home in connecticut
where at age 85 he seems to be busier
than ever gaston
could you film you do shout out gaston
what are you looking for some herbs
our day with jacques pepin began on a
splendid
late spring morning in his herb garden
just smell the parsley out of the garden
it's much stronger than oh great what
you get at the market and even testing
it
the parsley often doesn't have much
taste but that oh that does
taste still oh yeah we picked
ingredients for his recipe to create
the perfect plate of morning eggs
so you cook a lot uh i
not well oh well is it good
i try okay the key in this case is both
covering the eggs while they cook and
adding little water to the pan
so as you can see now
it glazes yeah yeah that's what we call
enough mirror
mirror eggs because it glazes the top
like that and of course
you can check it by pushing a little bit
like that to know
i like it pretty early some people like
it let's just cook it longer yeah
it's not a complicated recipe but it's
the sort of technique that papan has
spent a lifetime perfecting
growing up around his parents restaurant
outside lyon he apprenticed in french
cooking as a teenager
and worked his way up to becoming a top
chef in france
in 1959 he moved to the u.s where he
worked for howard johnson's developing
recipes in their new york city test
kitchen
it was through his friendship with julia
child that he became a household name
here
co-hosting a pbs show while introducing
america
to a whole new array of culinary
delights
and even this one c which was the big
hand
yes you said hand this is boston but
i live in connecticut the accent is
different
papan tapped into that wealth of
experience to produce
these short videos during the pandemic i
am doing a mint julep
for the kentucky derby what is it about
doing television and doing videos
that has sustained you and kept you
interested for
so long well i'm hungry all the time so
i mean i eat
cooking has been my life you know for
over 70 years and this is what i am
a tablespoon of butter in there two eggs
always break the egg on something flat
like this his latest videos are an
online treasure trove for both
experienced home cooks
and those still learning this is the
special trek a teaspoon of water
it seems like the memories made in the
kitchen
with kids especially are so visceral
yeah you know if you have a kid when he
comes back from school sitting down in
that kitchen
hearing his father's mother's voice and
the smell and the taste of that
that stay with you the rest of your life
at that point the food
transcend the physiological level of
feeding yourself
the food become home it become it become
love it becomes security
it become family you know so food memory
are very very powerful
in addition to the videos his 30th
cookbook is out
it's called quick and simple i wanted to
focus on making
people's life easier you know and uh and
actually using the supermarket as a prep
cook
you know you can go to the supermarket
get boneless skinless breasts of chicken
pre-sliced mushroom
pre-washed spinach you have a non-stick
pan to end with a minimum
amount of effort you can do you know
good food with us
for lunch he shared another slice of
culinary
nirvana mussels in hot sauce
zucchini and eggplant groton tomatoes
province all
and crab meat croquettes with tomato
relish
served with white wine followed by
orange cake
with grand marnier sauce it does seem
like this is a sort of
plate that gets you ready for summer oh
yeah absolutely
do you have a favorite season you like
to cook in
well i love spring i mean asparagus too
the strawberry and things are coming in
season
i always tell people to buy and season
because
when you buy a tomato in full season
first that one it's really a taste
secondly it's one the least expensive
thirdly it was
when it has all the nutritional good
that it should have in it
you know so why not buy in season i mean
without any question we'd had breakfast
and lunch but for papan the day was
still young
you just find your way everywhere there
was a trip up to his art studio
another one of his passions for more
than 50 years this is jacques this 21
you just you just did this
yes not too long ago yeah the umbrella
here
peppa my name means umbrella finally
no visit to papan's place is complete
without playing a round of the
century-old french game
patonk this is the questionnaire okay
small one
so you have to throw it between 20 and
30 feet
okay it's about there and then get as
close as you can
oh you got the backspin on there well
that's pretty good yeah you can
each team gets a set of steel balls
called
bull the object is to get the most bull
closest to the jack
which translated from french is called
the little pig
i gotta try to knock you out
look at that i think he's a hustler
that i gotta watch at 85
years old jacques papan has barely
slowed down
he's already got plans for an art show
this fall and his 31st cookbook is due
to come out next year
after seven decades he doesn't talk
about leaving a legacy
for him it's all about continually
sharing
his wisdom is there anything better than
good food
good wine and a game of petunk
maybe sex i don't know yeah
probably
there you go
where else am i supposed to kill you i
need you turn red
not easy
[Laughter]
what a lovely man so lovely and and it's
worth checking out these videos if you
get a chance with kids
wife husband whatever else um you know
they're short
and like they're just you just keep
watching them and you when you want to
learn and you want to get better at
cooking and you want to eat the stuff
the way he makes it
love the cameos by mrs glor and victoria
yes way to go nicole and victoria